let the music play on
covid may be keeping students at home
but the fall concert continues for
nearly 200
lva band students virtually in today's
what's cool at school
mr mcabee and i would like to welcome
you to the las vegas academy of the arts
fall virtual band concert
a full concert virtually a sentence too
often spoken in 2020
but talk about taking it to the next
level
[Music]
180 lva band students recorded video of
themselves playing their band part
from home
i think i recorded in the living room
it's a very detailed kind of two-month
process
from beginning to end that process a
labor of love with editing
distributing music rehearsing over
google meet and
students playing from nearly 200
locations
i had a few students respond that they'd
kind of forgotten about
concerts just because it's been so long
people can be reminded that like we're
still trying and we're still here and
we're doing our best
with band introductions performances
soloists
concert attire even red curtains it felt
like the real deal
proud parents siblings staff and friends
logged on for the experience
we even had some send in pictures of
family members you know all watching
together on the couch students pointing
at themselves in the video so it was
really awesome just to see everyone
put in that work
it was still just complete elation just
proof that
the students are still making music
pandemic aside
music will still be taught shared and
loved
they're still able to do their art and
they're still able to present their art
to an audience i think
just hearing that from so many of them
really
it it made me a little emotional and
that's what's cool at school
home addition if you know something
that's cool at school during these days
of distance learning
let us know about it send your email to
cool at school at 8newsnow.com